one of the most interesting chapters in
the history of humans in conflict is
whether or not humans sacrificed each
other historically there are records
especially when the Spanish
conquistadors and priests came to the
new world the Romans showed human
sacrifice and there freezes their hints
about it through the historical record
but did it really happen there's been
some doubt so in the last 15 20 years
archaeologists have taken new methods
bio archaeological methods where they
study skeletons and isotopes to look for
evidence of how the bodies were killed
in the 1920s Sir Charles woolly was an
archaeologist who excavated the tombs at
her which is now modern day Iraq and
what he found when he excavated the
royal tombs was this amazing funerary
procession that had been captured in
death so outside of the royal tomb of a
king or queen there were two guards
posted there were oxen carts with the
oxen still there and the groom's with
the oxen there were courtesans lined up
along the walls dressed in the women an
elaborate headdress there were people
arranged around musical instruments as
if they're at a concert in other words
this king or queen they don't know who
it was had taken all their servants with
them in death originally Willie thought
that these retainers had committed
suicide because he found cups and a
giant vat and he thought maybe they
drank the poison and this was the
prevailing view for decades since the
discovery but then a couple of years ago
a team at the University of Pennsylvania
Museum CT scanned a couple of the skulls
and they saw that underneath the helmets
that they were still wearing and
headdresses they had been killed by
blows to the side of the head along the
temple so they were not committing
suicide they were murdered and
sacrificed as part of the funerary
ritual
spanish priests had written in historic
records about really dramatic sacrifices
that took place atop high 6700 meter
mountaintops in the andes of the most
unblemished beautiful children that the
Inca had committed as offerings to the
mountain gods archeologist johan
reinhard went out with a team and
climbed to the top of these incredibly
high ND and mountains looking for these
sacrifices and indeed found in the late
90s and early 2000s mummies of children
who had been taken to the tops of these
mountains and sacrificed the most
dramatic example the best preserved was
as maiden that he has called the loulia
o maiden named after the volcano luli
akko in argentina where they found
almost a perfectly preserved girl who
was about 15 years old and a white
feather headdress with all sorts of
offerings of gold and silver statues and
next to her was a boy also in a
headdress with a silver bracelet and a
young girl who was maybe seven years old
when they studied the isotopes from the
hair of these children they found that
about a year before they were sacrificed
their diets had changed they were
suddenly being fed a diet of the elite
they were being fed meat more protein
and then about three months before they
actually were taken to the mountain tops
their diet changed again in other words
they were on the long trek eating stored
grain this is what the diet reflects on
the way to the mountaintop and when they
get there they also find traces of coca
leaf that had been used to drug them
probably before they were killed coca
leaves were stuffed in their mouths so
it's very interesting it gives a glimpse
of the last year and the lives of these
children who wear the sacrifices to the
mountain gods
violence gives us insight to these other
humans and how they see death and life
for example they're killing babies
they're killing children which seems
absolutely appalling to us that they're
sacrificing them in these bloody rituals
but when you study this violence you
begin to understand that by offering
children they these children being
deified they're turning into deities
themselves or when rulers take their
servants to death with them they see
death is a part of life there's an
afterlife and they're taking their
servants with them so it begins to give
us a sense of their worldviews and
violence for them is another way to to
show how they display power how they see
each other how they see their gods and
it's a clue to us to the past and to
human nature and what we're capable of
you